in a previous video we've given an
intuition on what foreign exchange
markets are all about in particular we
talked about the foreign exchange market
between the u.s dollar and the chinese
wan what we're going to do in this video
is think about the same idea but think
about it in terms of graphs and the
types of economic models that we're used
to seeing in an introductory
macroeconomics course so what we're
going to focus on in this video is the
foreign exchange market
exchange
market
for
the chinese
one now we're going to think about it in
terms of supply and demand curves it can
be a little bit confusing because we're
going to be thinking of the price of the
juan in terms of another currency in
this case the dollar although you could
do it in terms of other currencies the
pound the euro or whatever else now this
can be a little bit confusing because
we're going to be thinking about
currency on both axes but let's first
think about the horizontal axis that
when we're thinking about most markets
that is our quantity axis and here once
again we want to think about quantity
we're going to think about the quantity
quantity of chinese
of chinese
one and then our vertical axis we're
essentially going to be thinking about
the price of the chinese one but how do
you think about the price of a currency
well we're going to think of it in terms
of another currency and for the sake of
this video that other currency is going
to be the u.s dollar so this is going to
be u.s
u.s dollars
dollars
per
chinese
chinese one and i encourage you pause
this video think deeply about why it's
u.s dollars per chinese won as opposed
to chinese won per u.s dollars and think
about why i put the quantity of chinese
won here instead of the quantity of u.s
dollars because this is the foreign
exchange market for the chinese one i
could have done another chart where it's
a foreign exchange market for the us
dollar in which case then my quantity
would be us dollar and then i would
think of how much of some other currency
per us dollar so i would say maybe how
much chinese won per us dollar but
here's the other way around i'm in the
market for the chinese one
so let's think about the supply and
demand curves and which way they would
work
well imagine that people are offering
very few us dollars per chinese one well
in that world a lot of people might not
want to convert their want into dollars
they might not offer them up to up for
supply to be converted into us dollars
and so the quantity of chinese won if
the price for the chinese one is low
might be pretty low
and as the price people are willing to
pay in terms of dollars goes up well
more and more people might be willing to
transact
so our supply curve and here we're
talking about the supply for chinese one
is likely to increase as people are
willing to pay more for those wants and
this is like many markets that we've
seen before this is just a little bit
less intuitive because we're thinking
about markets for one currency in terms
of another currency
now what about the demand curve
well the demand curve is going to look
like a lot of demand curves we've seen
if the price of a chinese won is high
well very few people are going to demand
it and as the price of the chinese won
in terms of dollars is lower and lower
more and more people might demand more
chinese one because like hey it's
cheaper now in terms of u.s dollars so
this is what a demand curve might look
like
and as you could imagine this point is
our equilibrium point and it would tell
us our equilibrium exchange rate and so
we could call that our equilibrium
exchange rate and this would be our
equilibrium our equilibrium quantity
so for example
let's say that our equilibrium quantity
and let's say this is the quantity that
changes hands in some time period so
let's say per day let's say our
equilibrium quantity is equal to
one thousand one
one thousand
one
let me just call this q sub 1 is 1001.
these numbers are very low real exchange
markets we might be talking about
billions or tens or hundreds of billions
or even sometimes trillions of various
currency but let's just say for argument
it's 1 000 won is our current
equilibrium exchange quantity per day
and let's say this exchange rate e sub 1
is equal to 10 cents per one so 10
cents or one tenth of a u.s dollar
per chinese one so that's our current
exchange rate now let's say for some
reason all of a sudden americans are
very become increasingly interested in
converting their currency maybe they
want to invest in china maybe all of a
sudden the chinese say hey americans
come buy property in china a lot of
people are interested
well what would happen here
well then the demand for juan would
increase because you could only buy that
property in china with one not with us
dollars
and so what would happen here well your
demand curve would shift to the right
like we've seen before and so if we call
this d1
then we could get to a new demand curve
that might look something like this
d2
now what would happen if our equilibrium
exchange rate doesn't change
well if this is our exchange rate if
this were to stay our exchange rate
now all of a sudden a higher quantity is
being demanded then is being supplied
the americans in this situation or it
actually doesn't even have to be
americans it could just be whoever's
holding u.s dollars there's demand for
more than a thousand won per day maybe
this is 1500 won or whatever it might be
and so what you would naturally see is
that the price of the wand in terms of
us dollars will go up until you get to
an equilibrium point and on the first
video when we talk about the intuition
of foreign exchange markets we talk
about why this would be so you would
then get to a new equilibrium
right over here this is e sub 2 and a
new equilibrium quantity let's call this
q2 our new equilibrium quantity q2 might
be 1200 won per day versus 1001 per day
and our new equilibrium exchange rate
maybe this is now equal to 15 cents
per one instead of 10 cents for one
so big picture you can think of the
foreign exchange market in a lot of ways
like we've looked at other markets in
macroeconomics it's just a little bit it
takes a little bit of an intuitive leap
to just think about the market for one
currency in terms of another